Joe in Darfur in 2006 where she was
doing what she was brilliant at which
was looking after and saving the lives
of vulnerable refugees and here we are
today commemorating her life that's been
lost and of course the most profound
thing that's happened is that two
children have lost their mother a
husband has lost a loving wife and of
course parliament has lost one of its
most passionate and brilliant campaigner
someone who epitomized the fact that
politics is about serving others today
our nation is rightly shocked and I
think it is a moment to stand back and
think about some of the things that are
so important about our country the fact
that we should treasure and value our
democracy where members of parliament
are out in the public accountable to the
public available to the public and
that's how Joe died she died doing her
job I think the second thing is that we
should recognize that politics is about
public service people who go into public
life they want to act in the national
interest to pursue the national interest
to do things for other people to make
the country make the world a better
place politicians disagree with each
other we often disregard what
politicians say and we disregard each
other and the rest of it but at the end
of the day that's what it is about and
that is what Joe showed it is all about
but perhaps most important of all we
should value and see as precious the
democracy that we have on these islands
where 65 million of us live together and
work together and get on together we do
have peace we do have stability do we do
have a measure of economic well-being
better than other countries obviously
still to be spread far more widely and
it's all underpinned by tolerance so
where we see hatred where we find
division where we see intolerance we
must drive it out of our politics and
out of our public life and out of our
communities and if we truly want to
honor Joe then what we should do is
recognize that her values service
community taller
the value she lived by and work by those
are the values that we need to redouble
in our national life in the months and
in the years to come mr. Corbett
yourself and other senior politicians
granted a level of security beyond that
of the the rank-and-file the backbenches
of those hundreds of MPs concerns does
this raise for their Safety's they go
about their parliamentary business and
their day-to-day lives we need our whole
society to be secure Joe was brutally
murdered here 24 hours ago in this town
a town she loved the town she grew up in
serving a community she loved and in her
life she'd worked for anti-slavery
campaigns she'd worked for Oxfam she was
a campaigner for human rights and
justice all around the world she was
taken from us in an act of hatred in a
vile act that has killed her it's an
attack on democracy what happened
yesterday it's the well of hatred that
killed her she leaves behind her husband
who made a truly wonderful statement
yesterday a statement saying that in her
memory we would try to conquer hatred
with love and with respect she also
leaves behind two young children who
will never see their mother again they
would only be able to grow up knowing
what she was what she stood for and what
she achieved
I've asked the Prime Minister and the
speaker for the recall of parliament on
Monday and they've accepted that request
and Parliament will be recalled on
Monday so that we can pay do tribute to
her on behalf of everybody in this
country who values democracy values the
right of free speech and values the
right of political expression free from
the kind of brutality that Joe suffered
that's why we all need to come together
to understand that everyone must have
protection and security in order to
function in a democratic society Joe was
an exceptional wonderful very talented
woman taken from us in early 40s when
she had so much to give and so much of
her life ahead of her it's a tragedy
beyond tragedy what has happened
yesterday in her memory we will not
allow those people that spread hatred
and poison to divide our society we will
strengthen our democracy strengthen our
free speech she was a truly wonderful
woman I'm deeply sorry deeply sad of
what has happened to her my condolences
to all the people of badly and spin who
she represented so well and of course to
a wonderful family her husband her
children and all
of a white of them